kaliningrad va-t-elle connaître une
pénurie de marchandises c'est en tout
cas la crainte des habitants de cette
enclave russe coincée entre la pologne
et la lituanie car depuis ce week end le
pays balte interdit le transit par voie
ferroviaire sur son territoire de
certains produits en provenance de la
russie cela concerne les matériaux de
construction mais aussi le charbon ou
encore les ordinateurs et téléphones
portables
selon les autorités russes entre 40 et
50 % des importations pourraient être
soumises aux restrictions
les travaux de construction vont devoir
s'arrêter je pense notamment à la
rénovation des routes tous ne fera
qu'empirer je pense que beaucoup de gens
vont perdre leur emploi il n'y a pas
d'autre option
le gouverneur de kaliningrad a annoncé
que les marchandises soumises aux
restrictions seraient acheminées par
voie maritime d'ici une semaine de son
côté le kremlin exige la levée de cette
mesure
cette décision est vraiment sans
précédent c'est une violation de tous
nous comprenons que cela est dû à la
décision de l'union européenne d'étendre
les sanctions au transit nous pensons
que c'est aussi illégal la situation est
plus que sérieuse elle nécessite une
analyse approfondie avant d'élaborer des
mesures et des répliques cette analyse
approfondie sera faite dans les jours à
venir face aux menaces russe le chef de
la diplomatie européenne est venue au
secours du gouvernement lituanien
il n'ya pas de blocus le transit des
passagers et des marchandises non
sanctionnées se poursuit'
la lituanie n'a pris aucune restriction
nationales unilatérales
et ne fait qu'appliquer des sanctions de
l'union européenne
selon les autorités de kaliningrad le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
convoquera mardi l'ambassadeur de
l'union européenne à moscou
dans